foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
people we are back in Action
holy shmoly it has been a long time if
I'm not mistaken our last show the last
time you saw me before the Republican
debate in Milwaukee which we'll talk
about in a whole bunch more throughout
the next hour or so the last time you
saw me in studio back here in Miami in
the Free State of Florida was July 27th
that's when we shut down the Off the
Grid thing started a little bit early
because of the way the weekend worked
out and a few other things that we were
trying to accomplish so it has been
about five weeks uh with the exception
of the couple days in Milwaukee for the
Republican debate I have been completely
M.I.A Off the Grid we have been building
this brand new studio which I am super
psyched to finally show you guys today
it has been Blood Sweat tears Nails glue
plywood drywall all of the stuff I
really think what you're going to see
over the next couple weeks what we have
built here is the Primo Studio on the
internet we're going to be debuting a
couple new camera angles you're going to
see one new camera angle today but we're
gonna have a couple others that you're
going to be seeing over the next few
weeks we're not completely done with the
studio there's a few things
because of Joe Biden's economy that are
taken a little while to get delivered
things that should have been here weeks
if not months ago so we are going to
unleash all of that but I'm just so
proud uh just looking at it in the
camera here I'm so proud of what we
built here uh it's just so freaking
awesome I want to thank uh Connor and
Phoenix and Brock Guru in studio with me
right now these guys just busted their
butts over the last couple weeks on our
contractors and Architects and everyone
we worked with we're going to be
adjusting something so I have no doubt
that those of you in the comments will
be saying okay change this light let's
move this that this the other thing uh
we will be doing things on the fly but
more importantly than than any of that I
am incredibly excited to be back also
note there is a new camera angle you are
seeing a little more of my body and my
hands and you are now seeing the desk
people often said Dave we want to see
more of you I said that's a totally
different type of show but we split the
difference and you'll see a little bit
more of me right now we've got some old
stand-up tapes behind me over there all
kinds of interesting things basketball
signed by my man Clyde Drexler up there
the Constitution the Bill of Rights
couple other founding documents uh right
over that way and all sorts of stuff uh
real quick before we dive into it
Today's show is going to sort of be a
recap of some of what got me here and
that little intro that we played you up
top that was seven Studios worth of
stuff in this is now our 11th season we
started the Reuben report in 2013 uh
obviously it's 2023 right now we have
jumped through seven Studios real quick
for those of you that were playing along
at home and you can watch it again later
that first Studio of course we started
on The Young Turks I was there for about
a year uh the second one which you might
have noticed Ed Bagley Jr Actor Ed
Begley Jr with me that's the one people
don't really remember for about two or
three months right after I left the
Young Turks I was at a network called
Ryan ryot they were a startup digital
Network
we were there for about two months I
could tell they were kind of going in a
different direction and I wasn't really
thrilled with where things were headed
it was it was a lark it was just like
let's just try this thing and I
obviously I really wanted to leave The
Young Turks I don't even think Riot
exists anymore but it was it was all
good while we were there uh that was
Studio Number Two from there I went to
Aura TV and of course that was Larry
King's digital Network that's really
where the show started taking off that
was that first show uh with Sam Harris
who we're going to talk a bit about uh
coming up uh then after that after Aura
TV I would the show really blew up and I
realized you know I want to go
independent like why am I why am I doing
this for someone else I want to do it
for myself that's when I bought or we
bought our first house we moved into
what was the Primo studio in the show
full-on exploded and and became
something way bigger than I could have
ever anticipated our first garage studio
uh in Sherman Oaks California from there
in the midst of covid we moved to
another house in Florida because the the
riots were going by our doors and I
wasn't thrilled about that
so in any event we moved there and then
what you've seen and then of course we
moved to Miami and what we've been
showing you for the last year you were
just looking at a digital screen a lot
of people didn't know that it was just a
digital screen behind me a digital image
on a screen behind me of our last set
when we moved into this house there was
a there was a movie theater upstairs
that was perfectly soundproofed we were
so freaking busy moving here and moving
operations and everything else and then
life got crazy with two kids that we
just didn't have time to build out the
studio the way I wanted so it took us
about a year and a half but here we are
as of September 5th 2023 in the brand
spanking new uh studio and I just okay
just quickly though before I get lost in
all that uh on a personal note this uh
this off the great August thing uh I
think this year more than any other year
was probably the the most important to
me for a couple reasons you know first
off we had we have kids now who are
doing great by the way Justin's starting
to walk Luke's starting to talk like
it's all great getting away from the
machine a little bit really being able
to focus on them we did 10 days in a
Mexican rainforest I you know no phones
no TV no anything just purging I
literally as I said to Michael malice a
couple weeks ago
in Milwaukee I I didn't look at anything
I actually didn't even read any books
like this year I just we just sat and
relaxed and then of course we worked on
Studio stuff here but just purging
information and just coming back with
fresh eyes to all of this stuff so even
in the last couple days where I've
jumped back on Twitter a little bit to
see things and you see the old fights
and you see this one's angry at this one
and this one's canceling this guy and
that politician can't speak this one
blah blah blah it's like all right we're
back at the circus and it was a crazy
way to get back into the circus right so
I go three weeks off the grid then I
show up in Milwaukee like full on in the
circus it was all crazy but I'm really
refreshed ready to go I do want to show
you one other thing that happened the
locals people saw this about 10 days ago
I went for a facial okay it's part of
the skin care routine went for a routine
facial I wanted to come back looking
refreshed for you guys some sort of
chemical got in my eye and my God look
at this image that's right they had to
numb my eye and what you're seeing there
that turn Terminator one that you're
seeing there they then put some kind of
chemical in your eye to see if there's a
scratch and what you're seeing over my
cornea there I had a crazy chemical burn
basically on my eye and for about six
days basically couldn't see out of my
eye blurry vision very sensitive to
light there I am Dan Crenshaw style but
I am back in business I can see I am
psyched I am ready to go Connor should
we show them the new angle or did you
have a moment you want to spring it on
me why don't we show them one of our new
angles that we're going to have here at
the Reuben report when I'm doing stuff
there's a new angle for you look at that
and sometimes we're going to put stuff
wait over here and things will be
happening look at that hey is that
beautiful or what look at those
beautiful fluorescent lights I am very
very excited okay so what are we doing
guys we are back at it I said to Phoenix
this morning I want to ease a little bit
back in right like I don't want to like
just jump into okay here we go politics
blah blah blah I want to tell a story
story that I think is connected very
much to my years of going independent
how the constant battle between New
Media and old media is is really
encompassing so much of what is wrong
with everything right now and also
what's right with everything right now
and then we found actually the perfect
clip uh to kick us off today uh which
was Bill Maher yeah I'm still going to
talk about Bill Maher occasionally uh he
was on Joe Rogan's podcast and Joe Rogan
little known podcaster he's doing okay
down there in Texas uh talking about
independence the home studio and why
even a guy like Bill a Hollywood guy
tons of money an institution unto
himself why he now is even doing the
home studio podcast thing
how are you enjoying doing your podcast
you know I love it especially since I've
been thrown out of work by the strike
you know so it's what I have left plus
the touring uh but that you know touring
is a couple of weekends a month
podcasting doesn't take that much time
either I don't do it every day like you
but it's nice to have an outlet it's
also nice to be able to talk to people
uh in a non-political way yeah it's also
nice to have like a pre completely open
format so conversations can really air
out right you know when you you don't
have to worry about running out of time
and right you also you can kind of let
them breathe a little because sometimes
you really want to let someone talk for
a long time to try to before you try to
interject and pick apart their
conversation their argument you really
want to I want to know what you're
really thinking I don't want to be
confused again that's kind of what you
pioneered yeah and we're grateful for it
and
um I I do like that I also find
it's interesting the setting makes a big
difference as to what arouses
the furies on the left
if I said so many of the things that
I've said on Club random on a podcast on
Real Time on HBO
they would have had my head yeah but
somehow when I say it in the setting of
the podcast in my own home blowing the
pot smoke
somehow it's okay and I find that very
interesting
I find that interesting too and the
reason I find that interesting is
because remember it's not TV it's HBO
The whole idea of HBO as a network was
that that's where you could say all the
things you couldn't say on network
television even on regular cable
television HBO was this Bastion of free
speech HBO what did every comedian for
30 years up until let's say the last 10
years where most of them have gone to
Netflix or Hulu or do it on their own
where did you want your special you
would say I want an HBO special it
wasn't just I want a comedy special I
want an HBO special so it's interesting
that bill I've never heard him say that
before is now saying that there are
things he can say on his podcast that he
can't say on HBO it's also interesting
noting that bill is allowed to have
guests on his podcast
that he cannot have on real time which
is uh pretty interesting I do want to
say guys by the way uh Joe Rogan's
making about what is it 100 200 mil a
year
it's got a freaking red velvet curtain
behind it you know how much money we put
it we spared no expense on this studio
wait till you see when we have live
guests in here what it fully looks like
looks like and by the way speaking of
live guests uh we were supposed to have
Governor Ron DeSantis as our first live
in studio guest tomorrow that was going
to be it was going to be a great reveal
and you know it would have been just
like a perfect fitting thing because he
was so integral as to why I even moved
to Florida in the first place uh but of
course there was this uh very intense
hurricane that hit the west coast and
the northern part of Florida uh so he's
been focusing on that which by the way
he's doing that's a bit of a sidebar
he's doing an incredible job with uh so
we are going to do a a Skype interview
with him tomorrow not live in studio
we're shelving that we'll make it happen
but anyway the point of all this well I
wanted to show you that clip partly it's
that it frames this idea of Independent
Media the home studio the fact that
there's these new pipes like Rumble and
locals and everything else that allow
you guys to
get information in a in a hopefully
honest or I don't know slightly more
mature or decent way than you might get
from the networks but the networks still
want their control over you and they
have for quite some time what Bill Maher
was saying right there sounded very
familiar to me you might remember this
clip and this was also fitting for
today's sort of retrospective show that
we're doing uh Tucker Carlson you know
that guy Tucker Carlson was on Fox now
he's completely independent putting
stuff up on Twitter which I am told
Twitter is now known as X apparently
that happened while I was gone remember
Tucker five years ago coming to Little
podcaster Dave rubin's garage and saying
this
Tucker Carlson I am glad to have you
here my friend I'm glad to be here I
love this I don't know that anyone has
ever walked in here and been more
impressed by the Ruby because I work in
television so I know what this is and
it's just the coolest thing I've seen in
a long time are you jealous
are you joking yes I'm jealous you have
millions and millions of viewers I have
a massive staff
but I don't have the control that you
have which is wonderful
I don't have the control which you have
which is wonderful subsequently five
years later he is no longer with Fox
he's doing his own thing uh the war the
information war that Matrix style war
that I'm always talking about us versus
the machine it's all here now it is
absolutely all here right now and I want
to show you a clip now of Tucker Carlson
doing his new show which is on X Twitter
whatever you want to call it talking to
Dave Portnoy Now Dave Portnoy we've
showed some clips of him over the years
from bar stool Sports he is another I
would say digital Pioneer right he
wanted to do a sports thing he saw how
ESPN corporate ABC Disney owned ESPN was
going completely woke he started bar
stool Sports it absolutely blew up then
he then of course the machine tried to
cancel him all sorts of stuff but he has
turned it into an absolute Sports and
culture uh cultural Powerhouse and he
and soccer sat down over the weekend
now let me ask you this before the fox
unwinded and what you mean I got fired
yes did you think you like were you uh
Ardent like go fox go guy or do my view
on Fox hasn't really changed they let me
say whatever I want whatever I wanted
really for 14 years and I I'll never
stop being grateful for that
and then obviously I said too much and
I'm not exactly sure what I said that
was bad no one ever told me but one day
they're like nope can't have this
anymore and they fired me
and I even told them as they were firing
me like your business I made a pencil
look never worked for anyone else again
and I never will but
um I can't be mad about it I mean they
were they were great to me I think the
murdochs were always nice to me and uh
and one day for whatever reason they'd
had enough so I wasn't my feelings
weren't hurt I was not expecting it so
were you like when for me when I was
with
pen I knew there were things it's like
oh I can't go there they've made that
clear did you feel like that foxy could
say whatever you want well there was
always internal I mean did the murdochs
were always nice they never got in my
way at all they were always super nice
to me but there were you know small my
it's a company run by fearful women yeah
you know what I mean and they were
always like neck you know second-tier
people who are hassling my producers but
no one ever called me
company run by fearful women I don't
mean to make this about fox and I do go
on Fox obviously I'm sure I'll be on Fox
later this week they always let me say
whatever I want so I don't want to focus
on Fox so specifically here but this
idea of these sort of a company run by
like middle management I don't think it
means it matters if they're men or women
specifically like this managerial class
not the people who build anything right
so in that case the Murdoch's they built
the company right they built the media
Empire and not the people who tell the
people what they want to communicate
right like so Tucker is out there as the
as the star of the network so he's
producing something they're producing
the freaking pipes and the
infrastructure that allows people to
hear it but that there's this managerial
class in the middle and we see this
almost with everything in society
there's a bunch of people who create
almost nothing other than problems right
and they seem to be the ones that as
Tucker was saying didn't want to say
whatever it is that he wanted to say now
I also I also thought it was interesting
that what Tucker said there was that he
will never have another boss like this
I'm telling you guys like it's been
obvious to me for a long time I think if
you've watched me uh for if you've
watched me certainly for these 11 years
the beginning of that 2013 thing to now
but even if you've only watched me for
the last year like this battle
between mainstream media and whatever is
happening online not to say that me or
Tucker or Rogan or Bill Maher is right
about everything
and we may all have our weak spots and
blind spots and all those things
actually I have no doubt that we do and
I'm pretty sure they would all admit
that as well but the battle between
something that has been hyper controlled
that that feeds us lie after lie after
lie and gets people to swallow the lies
and then say thank you Mark and I thank
you sir may I have another versus the
bunch of people trying to figure out
something something sensible so that's
what people actually I can tell you this
over the last month when I was in
airports wherever I was going to the
food store wherever I was and people
would come up to me they always say the
same thing Dave you keep me saying Dave
I miss you everybody's crazy and it's
like that's all I'm trying to provide
for you here you can fill in the spots
if you think I missed something but the
point is that seems to be that whether
it's through the managerial class
whether it's the higher-ups at HBO as
Bill Maher is talking about whoever it
is there seems to be certain things that
you cannot say right whether it's HBO
whether it's Fox whether it's
you as a teacher and you want to say
that there are two genders whether you
want to teach an honest assessment of
History slavery blah blah blah whether
you want to say that the United States
is not systemically raises all of that
stuff and that's why Independent Media
scares the F out of the machine and the
people who want to keep SP spoon feeding
you nonsense
so that you will basically act like an
automaton so now let's shift over to
another guy that's been making some
sense to people uh here is a video of
Robert F Kennedy Jr who unfortunately
will not be on a debate stage with Joe
Biden because obviously the Democrats
are not going to allow that to happen
here he is talking about how the CIA
part of the machine uses their
propaganda machine against us the people
of the United States of America
there's a provision of the CIA Charter
that says that the CIA cannot propaganda
I see American people President Obama
adopted in 2016.
that essentially reopened the door for
operation Mockingbird so that the CIA
began once again to um to propaganda is
American how are they doing that
President high level intelligence
officials are or people associated with
the intelligent industry
are running those journals like Noah
schlachmann who runs uh a linkstone who
came from Daily Beast Daily Beast was
run by John Avalon who was you know who
has deep ties to the intelligence uh
agencies but even journals like
Smithsonian and Smithsonian and uh
National Geographic
nature
um The Washington Post the New York
Times appeared to be uh compromised by
the see I we know from uh
I'm the
um Twitter files
at both the FBI and CIA
were operating portals within the uh
Twitter and Facebook that allowed them
to manipulate information and to do to
de-platform people and to you know
silence certain people that they didn't
like in those in the social media
operation Mockingbird it was a an
operation to compromise American
journalists there were some 400 editors
journalists
um from you know all the largest
Publications the New York Times have
been compromised
um The Washington Post was what do you
mean by compromise for people who oh
they were functioning the high level
people at those
at those journals were actually were
working for the agency or had you know
signed uh secrecy agreements with the
CIA and at CBS ABC NBC after 75 when it
all came out during the church committee
hearings
the CIA promised that it would no longer
compromise American journalists it
continued the program to compromise
journalists all over the world and today
the CIA is the biggest funder of
Journalism in the world how about
President through USA ID
and that little Twilight Zone before you
fall asleep every night I'm thinking
about what I'm gonna do in the first
weeks when I get into office about
fixing these agencies
um one at a time you know that's
something I'm excited about
and that is unbelievably powerful stuff
and it's kind of like oh let's look
behind the curtains I don't want to see
that better put the curtain back because
you don't want to think that your
government in essence the the three
letter agencies have been weaponized
against you but interestingly and we'll
follow up with this tomorrow or Phoenix
maybe you can give me something on the
Fly he mentions this guy Noah shackman I
think his name is who I think now works
for Rolling Stone used to be the
editor-in-chief of Daily Beast he used
to write hit pieces about me all the
time and about the intellectual dark web
he called me all right I got into a big
fight with him so now really think about
this for a second this guy who RFK Jr is
saying is basically working for the CIA
who runs at one point was running Daily
Beast running uh running Rolling Stone
Etc uh he was running around calling a
whole bunch of people Jordan Peterson
Ben Shapiro et cetera et cetera I don't
mean to make this about me but you see
it right like you can see the thing that
they have the prism that they have that
they have put in front of everyone's
faces so everyone cannot get an honest
estimation of what is true anymore it is
absolutely insane and the question
really is for how long will they and
when I say they in this case I mean not
only the three letter agencies but
Google and YouTube and Facebook and
everything else how long is it that they
will allow people to have these
conversations on YouTube and elsewhere I
mean that's that literally quite
literally is the purpose of Rumble and
I'm glad to see that Elon is opening up
Twitter in a new way but these these
on-camera propagandists these people
some of them are sort of behind the
scenes they're the editors in Chiefs of
Rolling Stone and Daily Beast and daily
cause and all of these things that no
one knows no one feels like they ever
click it but everyone kind of knows
about it and they write mean things
about people who are the ones that we
see up front all the time well they're
out there all the time they're the late
night TV show hosts now they used to be
a bunch of really cool people Jack Parr
little before my time but I've watched
some of the old clips like actually
funny and interesting and irrelevant
Johnny Carson who you know probably my
my greatest comedy hero but now we've
got guys that are just completely sold
out to the machine like Jimmy Kimmel
like Stephen Colbert like the rest of
those guys so as you may know right now
there is a writers strike in Hollywood
and these people they're not funny when
they have a team of 20 Riders but you
take away the team of 20 writers and
they're deeply unfunny so what are they
doing while none of their shows are on
right now because they can't just do
what a lot of the rest of us do which is
just get up here have a couple people in
studio with them and just tell you what
they think God forbid they do that uh
well they're all starting a podcast and
uh here the big five I guess that's what
they are the big five late night show
hosts are starting a podcast it's called
Strike Force Five and here's a portion
of it
Jimmy yeah hi I'm Jimmy Fallon I'm
Stephen Colbert I'm Jimmy Kimmel I
thought when you said Jimmy you meant me
Jimmy but you meant Jimmy Jimmy I always
mean you but when you always be at Myers
who do you mean I mean John Oliver makes
the five of us together for uh maybe an
hour a day Strike Force Five is the name
of our podcast subscribe to it now
Spotify or wherever else you get your
podcasts but Spotify you
can you put the other camera angle on
can you imagine anything worse than that
I can't that is absolutely terrible
first off the fact that these people
that you know how much money these guys
have you know I put a couple hundred
grand into the studio we I'm telling you
we spared no expense and I will do
anything else that we have to to make
this the most beautiful perfect show we
can possibly bring to you and mostly I
want to thank I want to thank all of you
that that support me to do this
especially those of you and locals that
keep us independent and allow us to do
all of this stuff but these guys are
starting a podcast together and it looks
like crap and they're on their camera
their little webcam things and all that
but who does anyone watch I mean I don't
know that anyone's watching it just but
just the idea these guys should also
hate each other do you remember when
Leno and Letterman the late night Wars
there's a book written about it and
there was a great HBO movie about it
what was it called The Late Shift about
the Leno and Letterman when Carson was
retiring and who was going to get The
Tonight Show they hated each other
because they were different at comedy
right like Letterman was sardonic and
irreverent and sarcastic and Leno was
kind of
Leno was kind of Evergreen and pleasant
whatever some people like One some
people like but they hated each other
these guys love each other because
they're all just sycophants for the
machine but Dave what do you mean
they're sycophants for the machine
please give us evidence of that sort of
thing here's one of my favorites this
was Pete covid nonsense from blackface
Jimmy Kimmel Dr fauci said that if
hospitals get any more overcrowded
they're going to have to make some very
tough choices about who gets an ICU but
that choice doesn't seem so tough to me
vaccinated person having a heart attack
yes come right on and we'll take care of
you unvaccinated guy who gobbled horses
goo rest in peace Wheezy you're
oh yeah so unvaccinated people should
basically drop dead that was the comedy
the quote-unquote comedy that Jimmy
Kimmel was giving us I know we've showed
you that clip before let's go to another
one from The Archives this might be if
when you when you look back when when
people when historians when sociologists
scientists
aliens look back on the three years of
covet Insanity which by the way they're
trying to bring back right now we'll
have a little more on that in just a sec
when people look back on covet Insanity
This Moment by Stephen Colbert might be
the Pinnacle of the pathetic sold out
grotesque vomiting
that covid brought us through the
mainstream media
the vaccine
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever
[Music]
team
[Applause]
[Music]
la la
[Applause]
la
[Music]
vaccine
how that man didn't go home right after
that open up his mouth a gun and
blow his brains out
we're back baby uh I have no idea I
honestly have no idea but link that
think about that right there you have
this guy who makes out can we check how
much Colbert makes here let's say he
makes 10 or 15 million dollars a year so
a giant Corporation pays him 10 or 15
million dollars a year to do comedy but
what he really is doing is activist work
for the machine for the Democrat Party
uh for big Pharma everything else wow 15
million dollars a year
Jesus I'm in the wrong line of work
anyway
he does that now let's connect that to
where we started where you have Bill
Maher saying you know there's certain
things on HBO I can't say so I do a
podcast there's Joe Rogan basically
saying that's why I do this podcast
there's Tucker going well you know Fox
never told me what I couldn't say but I
kind of could figure out what I couldn't
say and then you see what the machine is
right and what is the machine well it is
something that constantly wants to lie
to you so it can inject you with all
sorts of stuff and lie to you and lock
you down you will you all know that
already of course but here's Rachel
Maddow in case you forgot it means that
instead of the vaccine being able excuse
me it means for instead of the virus
being able to hop from person to person
to person to person spreading and
spreading sickening some of them but not
all of them and the ones that it doesn't
sicken don't know they have it and then
they give it to even more people because
they didn't recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus stops with
every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
that means the vaccines will get us to
the end of this
okay so what's interesting about that
clip and the reason I've shown it to you
probably 10 or 15 times over the last
two years is because I think you have to
think about it this way the cynical
version of that would be that she's a
liar right that she knew she was lying
and she's also an actress in the way she
says everything so assuredly and all
that stuff the cynical version is she's
just a liar and she does it for whatever
reason the less cynical version I think
is probably the more true reason which
is that she's doing exactly what she's
paid to do which is just repeat the
regime talking points right she had no
idea right there was no way at that
point that early on what was the date on
that that was like September of 21 if
I'm not mistaken uh so that was April of
21. there was simply no way there wasn't
enough data there wasn't enough time
that had gone by or anything else to
know that this was going to be the
perfect vaccine of all time and all of
that stuff but she sold it for you
because she is a servant of the machine
of course the Servants of the machine
also include the president of the United
States you might remember this one from
I believe this was June of 21. the the
various shots that people are getting
Now cover that they're they're you're
okay you're not gonna you're not gonna
get coveted if you have these
vaccinations yeah oh I missed that guy
well Joe you're not going to believe
this because I know they don't let you
hold your own phone but according to the
Tweeter breaking
Jill Biden Dr Jill Biden she has covet
yeah she got it today uh Brockton a
little double checking for me on this
one Dr Jill Biden Dr Jill she's double
vaxxed and double boosted and she has
coveted now is she gonna have to hide
and quarantine and stay away from 80
plus year old Joe Biden and got all of
the usual nonsense they lied about
everything
speaking of liars here's Little Anthony
fauci recap
on vaccines do you think that we will
need booster shots this year do you
think that is something on the distant
Horizon do you think that's something we
should be thinking about in 2021
I don't know to be quite honest with you
Rachel I don't know I believe that
sooner or later we will need a booster
because the immunity might Wane and
start to trickle down but I don't know
right now none of us know whether it's
going to be a year from now or longer or
a little bit less
yeah I have to tell you perhaps the most
Pleasant thing about being off the grid
was just like not hearing his voice like
it wasn't just that I didn't hear about
Trump I didn't hear anything from Biden
but just like not hearing Fati the
reason I'm doing sort of a recap of
everything is I'm really trying to drive
home what I think will be especially as
we roll into this next big election uh
the theme of the show going forward
which is there will be a set of people
trying to do something roughly true
roughly true and then there will be a
set of people that will lie lie lie and
you are all going to be disappointed in
in friends and family members who will
want more of the lies people who will be
on the fence that you're like oh maybe
after all these years they kind of get
it or why do they keep getting coveted
after all the booster shots and Jill
Biden twice backs twice boosted she's
got coveted maybe I should think about
this stuff a little bit differently and
still a huge percentage of people will
will fail you when they bring back masks
which they're trying to do and they push
more of axes when they lock down
whatever it is that they're trying to do
you are going to be sore poorly
disappointed not just in the corporate
people who will be pushing it based on
no evidence or anything else but on your
friends and your family and and those of
us who are again roughly sane who are
ballparking towards the truth uh we
better kind of come together because it
is going to get wacky uh in the next
year and a half leading up to this uh
big election uh one more on fauci
because the the thing with fauci is that
the fact that he is still now in
September of 23 that he is still now on
television that he hasn't been shamed
into Oblivion that he still shows up and
that they don't mock him relentlessly
well they often do uh is is just
incredible here he is this is uh two
days ago I believe on CNN with Michael
Smerconish uh talking about mask
efficacy watch this I would hope that if
in fact we get to the point where the
volume of cases as such and
organizations like the CDC recommend CDC
doesn't mandate anything I mean
recommends that people wear masks I
would hope that they abide by the
recommendation and take into account the
risk to themselves
and to their families and again we're
not talking about there's forcing
anybody to do anything
totally understood there is a perception
out there by many how many I don't know
that they don't work and that the data
concludes that they didn't work in the
first go round respond to that on masks
yeah well that's not so the most
rigorous and comprehensive analysis of
scientific studies conducted on the
efficacy of masks for reducing the
spread of respiratory illness including
covid-19 was published last month its
conclusions said Tom Jefferson the
Oxford epidemiologist who is the lead
author were unambiguous there is just no
evidence that they masks make any
difference he told the journalist Mayan
damasi full stop but wait hold on what
about the n95 masks as opposed to the
lower quality surgical or cloth masks
makes no difference none of it he said
well what about the studies that
initially persuaded policymakers to
impose Mass mandates they were convinced
by non-randomized studies flawed
observational studies how do we get
beyond that finding of that particular
review
yeah but there are other studies Michael
that show at an individual level for
individual when you're talking about the
effect on the epidemic or the pandemic
as a whole the data are less strong
individual level for an individual
that's so interesting because you fauci
were the guy pushing for lockdowns and
school closures which weren't at the
individual level right you weren't
saying oh you have covid
don't go to school today you were trying
to shut down the entire school oh you
have covered don't go to work today no
you were trying to shut down the entire
economy so even when he's confronted
with studies that say masks do jack
and we all know it right we all knew it
from beat one everyone knew it right if
you if you had a one firing neuron left
in your brain which I know they're
trying to destroy between mainstream
media and social media and endless
clicking and blah blah blah blah but if
you were thinking a little bit everyone
knew you put these claw things on your
face whatever that stupid thing was it
was open here it was open here it was
open here it was open here when you'd
meet someone on the street you'd take
your mask down to talk to them because
you couldn't hear anything you'd go to a
restaurant somehow if you were sitting
you could take your mask off if you were
standing I guess kovid couldn't get over
six feet but it could be it was every
literally every bit of it was nonsense
and I do want to go on the record one
more time I will never be being injected
with any of your nonsense and I am never
putting on a mask again whether it's the
alien invasion you tell me I have to put
the mask on or the zombie apocalypse or
covet 9 none of it I am not playing your
games anymore and I'm very proud to say
I didn't I you know within the I did the
two weeks of stop the spread
but I ain't doing any of it and I was
and I'm very proud to say that I was uh
awoke awakened on this thing uh pretty
early on but what is really going on
here it seems to me
that what we've laid out here on this
new Reuben report set today is that we
have a government bureaucracy these
three letter agencies that seem to be
pulling the strings
of our old world mainstream media and
the entertainment and governmental
institutions that are supposed to
protect our freedoms and instead they're
they're empowering them to push uh push
away our freedoms take away our freedoms
and we are going in essence from a
democracy to a tyrannical regime and
this is happening all over the West cue
a video of world leaders exposing
themselves for what they are tyrants
individuals are allowed to make their
own choices there may be all sorts of
different reasons why someone is
hesitant to get vaccinated and therefore
while not forcing anyone
to get vaccinated enforcement measures
in place will make sure
that everyone is vaccinated people
their jobs to keep
to keep now do you retract your
statement that they were not forced
all right Senator no I I believe firmly
that nobody was forced to have a vaccine
it's people that don't want this
mandatory vaccine how do we manage that
well then they won't be going to work
it's very very simple I believe
everybody was offered an opportunity to
get a vaccine or not get a vaccine I
don't believe that anybody was forced to
take a vaccine we have said no you must
get vaccinated in terms of the vaccine
mandates I acknowledged that it was a
challenging time for people but they
made ultimately made their own choices a
vaccine mandate is being expanded to
around 40 percent of all workers you
basically set the two different classes
of people if you're vaccinated or if
you're unvaccided you have all these
rights if you are vaccinated that is
what it is so yep Hospitality
hairdressers and gyms can operate at all
levels if they ask customers for a
vaccine certificate there was no there
was no compulsory vaccination people
made their own choices and so it follows
that if customers must be vaccinated
then so too must the workers
I want to be clear guys uh we're going
to have a compulsory non-vaccination
policy here at the Reuben report when
they come back when they bring back
covert and you know it's coming right
before the election I'll talk to the
camera it's coming right before the
election they're going to bring it and
again it's going to be alien apocalypse
climate whatever the hell they're coming
up with and they're coming up with it
because people keep falling for this BS
right that's how it is but I just want
to be clear to the people in this studio
if you are vaccinated you are fired I am
not going to have your freakish blood
anywhere near me that's the way we're
doing it okay I'm not risking it I've
got kids now I can't have you weirdos
near me but why am I doing this right
why am I come back to am I focusing on
covid and the lies and all of that
because it is still happening people I
saw this one this morning and I was like
because remember even though I've been
somewhat back on the grid for the last
10 days we've mostly been big fixing up
the studio and everything else I was
checking the news a little bit but I
really just officially Dove back in this
morning a little bit yesterday and then
this morning I saw this uh this tweet by
jaybody Chariot now you guys know Jay by
Charlie I've had him on the show several
times uh he is a scientist and professor
at Stanford University he is he he was
one of the one of the original people
doing it right on coven from beat one he
is now advising Governor DeSantis here
in Florida uh when it comes to pandemics
and things of that nature check this out
uh what's happening over at Michigan
University right you know University of
Michigan at the University of Michigan
students testing positive testing covet
positive must leave their dorms for five
days and live in the community a hotel
room or a relative's house is okay this
cruel policy is designed to spread covid
from the University into the wild it
won't stop covid from spreading and he
tags University of Michigan and you can
see he has their policy down there so
really think about this Insanity that is
still happening right now University of
Michigan is supposedly an elite school
right that means a kid
this is a 19 year old kid right he's a
sophomore at University of Michigan he
gets coveted he's around a bunch of
other young healthy people now a lot of
them are taking bong hits I suppose it's
college and I guess that could affect
your lungs over a period of time but
most of them are pretty healthy what
you're saying is you gotta get out you
gotta go to a hotel oh don't infect your
dorm mates and the kids who are all
young and healthy go to the random Hotel
oh go to your relatives kill Grandma but
we're back at the beginning and again a
certain amount of people are always
going to swallow it so guys you gotta
just remember as we move forward through
the madness it's not just the mainstream
Media or the late night TV show hosts
that are increasingly becoming
irrelevant or the government it's
actually all the pundits it's the entire
machine so who else is propagandizing
you and can't pull their heads out of
their butts I was 50 50 on showing you
this clip that we're about to show you
because as I mentioned earlier in 2015
when when the Reuben report officially
took off when I started doing a long
form interview show show so we had left
The Young Turks already where I was
doing more of like a view Hot Topics
kind of thing and we started doing the
long form interview my first sit down it
was it was basically eight years ago
this week if I'm not mistaken it was
SEPTA I think we did it on September 9th
today September 5th we did it on
September 9th uh 2015.
it was with Sam Harris a neuroscientist
and mindful meditation expert I guess
you could say Sam Harris and he had been
an outspoken critic of religion he was
part of the new atheists all this and he
was getting involved in politics he was
also very critical of collectivism and a
lot of the stuff that was wrong with the
left and
okay that was the first interview that I
did over the last couple years Sam has
sort of you know we've watched the new
atheist movement fall apart Sam really
kind of went crazy with Trump
derangement syndrome this segment you
know you know what I'm gonna actually
make an official state this is the last
time we're going to talk about him on
the show because this actually brings me
no pleasure because Sam and I became
friends he and his wife came over to
dinner at our house many many times we
went out a lot and watching him kind of
go off the deep end so this is the last
time we're going to talk about him on
the show uh but Sam Harris uh who was in
who is the reason I'm playing this is
because he was one of the thought
leaders of what was thought to be the
same left uh he went on Russell Brand's
podcast and Russell Brand I would
include in an actual saying left he may
be the only guy left half of Bill Maher
but Russell Brand has podcasts on Rumble
Sam went on there and they talked about
big Pharma and and listened to Sam after
all of this coveted craziness all of the
lies all of the money that they made and
the immunity that they got from lawsuits
and everything else Sam's still
defending big Pharma there's some
trade-off between
uh
remunerating people for the risks they
take and and the and the and the and the
work they do and allowing despite the
despite the obvious possibility of weird
incentives allowing for people to get
spectacularly wealthy when they get
lucky based on their own intelligence
right they they they produce something
that's immensely valuable to us a new
antibiotic and we should let them get
rich right and if you have an
alternative to that well by by all means
uh express it but to my knowledge we
haven't found one I would like to
express an alternative but also outline
a few things within your hypothesis no
one is conducting that research at
Pfizer precisely because it isn't
profitable so this tells us precisely
the mentality that governs at Pfizer and
when indeed there is innovation you
might find that it came from bioentec in
Germany who are funded by the German
taxpayers and you might find that
Pfizer's profits were garnered by
charging the American taxpayers who paid
for that Pfizer
apparent Pfizer Innovation but actually
a bioentec Innovation anyway look I
really want to give the devil his due on
this one I am all for people getting
rich I love capitalism and if you bring
something to the market you create an
incredible new vaccine that actually
works you create an incredible new glass
that holds water in it so people
foreign
that guy deserves some cash I am all for
that the problem is as Russell is
alluding to the entire system is rigged
you don't want to create a system where
big Pharma is completely uh unable to be
sued if they kill a whole bunch of
people or where they can hide all of
their records or the same people who are
supposed to be watching what big farm is
doing all end up in the government or it
turns out that the people like Anthony
fauci who are supposed to protect us
from viruses are also funding things
like gain of function research in Wuhan
Labs
etc
etc so unfortunately I think that's a
little bit of a blind spot for Sam but
really I'm it's not it brings me no
pleasure but the point of that
was that the last limbs the last Libs
the people that I focus on all the time
and why do I do it is it partly because
where's the book it's over this shoulder
the first book don't burn this book it
was a defensive Classical liberalism
which is a set of ideas worth defending
individual rights and laissez-faire
economics and logic and reason these are
all worth defending but if you want to
defend those things you must get rid of
all of these people that I've been
critiquing and mocking throughout the
show and and the people that they end up
voting for and mostly that is the
Democrats at this point and that does
not mean you have to be a republican
right because the Republicans will fail
you as Peter Thiel often says uh we have
the evil party and the stupid party the
evil party's Democrat Party the
Republicans are the stupid party doesn't
mean the Republicans are great you get
some Diamonds in the Rough every now and
again right you get the santis every now
and again you get what's happening in a
highly functional Florida every now and
again but the people that can be moved
right now
are the people who are those ex-libs
like we have this crazy election coming
up right and we shall see and I I do not
believe we'll save this for tomorrow and
the rest of the week and the rest of the
year like I don't think any of the polls
make sense I I it it's there's so much
nonsense in the system right now The
Ether has been poisoned and and it's
it's putrid at the moment
but there is a certain set of people
that can move
right it's not the hardcore leftist woke
lunatics it's not the ultra right people
right but there is this certain type of
person that can move so now let's flash
back to Rogan with Mar uh discussing uh
how the woke and the extremists have
destroyed the term liberal something you
all know well about but it is worth
repeating because those are the people
that we got to save
because you don't toe the line they
should be you you're like a 90s liberal
you're like liberals back when they're
more reasonable before they became
leftists and now every liberal kind of
has to be a leftist it's not it's not if
you want to be on the team you got to
subscribe to the most Fringe ideas that
the team is promoting and I get in
trouble with that too it's strange I'm
always trying to make the case that
liberal is a different animal than woke
yeah because it is and you can be woke
with all the nonsense that that now
implies
um but don't say that somehow it's an
extension of liberalism right because
it's most often actually an undoing of
liberalism so you can have your points
of view and your positions on these
things but don't try to piggyback on
what I've always believed I have always
believed as liberals do for example in a
colorblind society that the goal is to
not see race at all anywhere for any
reason yes that's what liberals always
believed all the way through Obama going
back Kennedy everybody Martin Luther
King that's not what the wolf believed
they believe race is first and foremost
the thing you should always see
everywhere which I find interesting
because that used to be the position of
the Ku Klux Klan
that we see race first and foremost
everywhere all right people I know what
you're thinking because I can read your
mind through these computer waves uh
Bill you're right about a lot of stuff
but then you get the conclusion wrong
right he also said as Brock just pointed
out this idea that Obama was colorblind
is completely insane but which side are
you planting your flag on look we live
in a two-party system it is what it is
you may not like that you may want us to
have more of a you know European style
democracy where they have all of these
different parties and you know there's
10 different parties trying to create a
coalition so that you can really just
vote for the people who are you know it
might just be a micro party that is
really just focused on your issue I want
weed everywhere and you can vote for
that party and maybe they can get in the
Coalition and do something you might
want that but we happen to live in a
two-party system right now so if you
Bill Maher want to live say this with
love Bill if you build more and you Joe
Rogan if you want to live in that
colorblind Society you cannot vote for
Democrats you cannot yes you can say and
it's the same thing I said when I had
RFK Jr on here about two months ago it's
like you're you're still sort of
thinking of the Democrats of yesteryear
as if they're the Democrats of today so
I get it you can name a lot of old
Democrats I can name a whole bunch of
dead Democrats who made a lot of sense
years ago but
Joe we're not in the 90s anymore so Joe
if I'm not mistaken doesn't vote I could
be wrong on this I'd be happy to be
corrected if I am uh but he he I guess
didn't have the balls or he can talk
about politics all day long but didn't
vote I actually don't even mean that as
an attack on him what I'm saying is now
get to the conclusion you gotta damn
well vote for Trump or DeSantis or
whoever it's going to be on the
Republican side if we we have any chance
to get out of this right and and Bill
you can't the day before the the
midterms like you did uh just about 10
months ago you can't say you have to
vote Democrat if you want to save
democracy all the while the house is
burning
and we got bigger problems that in
essence is what I said to Bill Maher one
year ago this very week
first of all you got to break up with
your boyfriend Donald Trump who would
you say is more authentic him or Joe
Biden him he's more authentic him or
Elizabeth Warren but authentic does it
mean good if you're authentically a
crazy person pretty good when he was
president what what was pretty good we
weren't in a recession the Border was a
little bit better we didn't have a crazy
war in Ukraine like he hasn't conceded
the election for four years when he was
president Hillary Clinton he's an
illegitimate president he didn't say
that yes she did I met him and I I kind
of was like all right he's not evil he's
not Hitler and he's certainly not a
homophobe they used to have these Trump
rallies on Sundays they didn't burn down
Rodeo Drive like black lives matter and
I'm telling you you could have walked in
that audience yes would a certain amount
of people have been like I Bill
Maher and but but you know what a lot of
people would have been there like you
know what Bill Mars here that's pretty
cool think how different that would be
than if you went to an AOC rally where
you would be hated Beyond imagination
you're right it's just true it's just
they're they're the left or more purists
yeah so look I don't like sides everyone
wants to evolve out of oh you're blue
you're red you're Republican you're a
Democrat you're this you're that liberal
conservative
but within this fight that we are in we
have a limited set of choices and and I
think especially within the the
framework of an upcoming election we got
to do our damn disk guys to wake up the
people who watch Rachel Maddow is she
does she still have a show what happened
to her they booted her right I don't
even know if she no no she does or she's
a chronic the point is we have to wake
up those people we have to wake up the
the NPCs the people who still want to
swallow the lies the people who will
comply and put on the mask when they
tell them the people who won't go to
work when they tell them they want the
people who will Who will swallow the
lies that that they absolutely know to
be untrue oh oh they didn't lock us down
they said they didn't lock us down they
said they didn't force us to be
vaccinated but a certain set of people
will continue to do it and it is our job
and it is my job in this new studio
where you can see me now with the desk
let it freeze man uh it is my job and
your job as a sane person to wake up as
many people as possible uh I don't know
if you can tell but I am feeling
rejuvenated and reinvigorated and I am
ready to roll uh I know today's show is
a bit of sort of the the greatest hits
in terms of the theme of what we do here
obviously that's not what we're going to
be doing every day going forward we're
going to be diving back into all of the
madness and I promise you
to all of the people that say hello to
me at Whole Foods and at the airport I
will continue to try to keep you sane uh
because that's the exchange right for
those of you that have afforded me and I
really mean this to the people on locals
that for the people that throw in a
couple bucks so that we can stay
independent for all of the reasons that
I just laid out over this last 57
minutes uh the exchanges for a couple
bucks a month or whatever it is that you
throw in uh that the favor I can give
back to you is that I can communicate
some of this so we can wake up some more
people and then man
maybe we can get that to scale and we
can save this thing I actually think we
can I should note that we only played
one very minor clip about seven seconds
of the elderly man pretending to be
President Joe Biden on the show today so
we're going to cold close it with him we
are going to do a post game show as we
always do at reubenreport.locals.com in
about 30 seconds I thank you for
watching let's go to that side shot one
more time
you're good people thank you for
watching the program we'll be back
tomorrow thanks guys I I'm super psyched
to be back and again thanks to to the
guys in this room thanks to you guys at
home and we are going to be expanding
you're going to see all sorts of
different angles different things uh
live in studio audience or live in
studio audience
I may be saying too much we're going to
do some live in-person interviews here
maybe there's something else happening
with an audience but I can't swear to
that I'm not on trial here
goodbye
can you imagine looking at your child
we're changing people's lives we beat
farmer this year think about what you'd
think about how quickly forget takes
everything away from you without unions
there be no middle class if I'm sick of
this stuff well I'm sick and tired of
Smart Guys
not more fewer he was a patriot there is
not a single thing we can not do not a
single thing
thank you
go get him
[Applause]
[Music]